bonsoir bonsoir heureux de vous avoir
alors vous êtes donc comme je viens de
le dire le leader de la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire
alors dites moi on va refaire les choses
calmement parce qu'on dit toujours
krivine laguiller tout ça ils sont à
l'extrême gauche à la gauche de la
gauche alors assez rapidement sinon je
vais être obligée de vous vous arrêtez
de vous faire écouter l'hymne ouvriers
savent que personne s'en remet à la
presse m si vous aimez immigrés je vous
mets de choix non sérieusement
c'est quoi la lcr c'est à dire vous êtes
trotsky c'est à dire vous n'êtes pas
communiste et pas socialisée trotskiste
en quelques mots s'il fallait expliquer
votre position en politique parce que je
crois que les gens vous connaissent les
gens connaissent l'extrême gauche mais
ils savent pas à quoi ça correspond
exactement
non mais vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
je crois que ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'extrême gauche on pourrait
presque la paix la gauche dans la mesure
où la gauche une politique de droite je
veux dire c'est à dire que c'est un
courant politique avec plusieurs
organisations la plus connue les plus
connus ces luttes ouvrières est la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire c'est à dire
qu'on se bat pour un changement réel de
société on pense que jusqu'ici on a fait
du replâtrage il ya eu beaucoup de
mouvements sociaux dans l'histoire il ya
eu le front populaire il ya eu la
libération il ya eu mai 68 mais chaque
fois il faut commencer parce que on
s'attaque pas aux racines je veux dire
de tout ce qu'on peut déplorer de tout
ce qui aujourd'hui nous met en colère
que maintenant que maintenant que les
socialistes ont admis l'économie de
marché maintenant que les communistes
depuis robert russes sont inconscients
de salissure 1/2 l'économie de marché
enfin bon c'est la pyrrhus oui voilà
donc vous y atteler est ce que vous êtes
pour la révolution
ça dépend ce que ça veut dire et faire
la révolution
unique et ça veut dire si solution si on
découvrait qu'il demande banner
justement si les images de la révolution
qui est un peu l'image de la fikin c'est
à dire on prend tous les fusils des
mitraillettes on va pas à tout les
réverbères un patron a cure et un
adjudant et non maintenant ça c'est
ridicule cela aurait peut-être des gens
qui pensent à 1005 ou non je crois que
la révolution faut le prendre au vrai
sens du terme c'est à dire un changement
radical faut révolutionner le
fonctionnement de cette saison comment
vous allez faire parce que vous êtes
présenter aux présidentielles on
pourrait penser que soient évidemment en
des curés aux réverbères des patrons
comme les de le dire soit vous présenter
aux présidentielles et vous êtes l'élu
et une fois vous êtes président de la
république effectivement vous fait la
révolution je dirais d'une façon
pacifique et légale mais en 69 vous avez
eu 1,05 pour cent des voix et en 74 0 35
donc vous n'êtes pas près d'être présent
la république donc comment vous allez la
faire de révolution j'ai pas fait de
coup d'état non moi je crois que ce que
vous appelez la révolution c'est à dire
un changement radical de société c'est
possible que quand des millions de gens
le veulent imaginez que vous ayez été
élu en 69 ans 74 j'étais président
gérard lenorman
imaginez qu est ce que vous feriez si
vous étiez président de la république
d'abord je crois qu'on n'est pas comme
ça il lui présentera un public s'il ya
un grand mouvement derrière mais moche
pas qu'il ya des mesures immédiates à
prendre parce qu'ils sont première
mesure que vous prendriez si vous étiez
présent dans le public à la première
mesure concerne interdire tous les
licenciements des entreprises qui font
du profit je crois
révolutionnaire pour s'éclater
scandalisé de voir un type comme michel
jarre merci parce qu'il met dans ma
profession un type comme michelin qui
annonce fièrement j'ai fait 10 % de
profits mais actionner un vol casse pour
son rendement je vire 10% de les
ouvriers savent interdire faut interdire
ce genre de licenciement moi je donnais
des arguments comme ça ça peut marcher
c'était il ya une deuxième mesure par
exemple immédiate vous avez des millions
de gens aujourd'hui on plaisante on se
marre c'est bien de se marrer d'ailleurs
un peu mais enfin qui sont en dessous
des minima sociaux qu'ils vivent ou
survivent avec 2000 3000 francs par mois
moi je pense qu'il faut augmenter de
mille cinq cents enfants tout de suite
tous les minima sociaux en fuite rue
classe
jusque là mais tout cela est encore
le retour de la camarguaise par exemple
quelle est la différence avec arlette
laguiller j'ai trotskistes ou les
deuxièmes enfin oui trotskiste pour
beaucoup de gens c'est pas trop ce que
ça veut dire la crosse lycée présente
stalinisme et jeanne oui c'est ça
c'était mais moi je n'ai pas tellement
ce terme parce que c'est ya pas de culte
de la personnalité je crois que trotsky
qui a été un des leaders a évolué sans
russe a joué à son époque un rôle très
éminent justement pour montrer que ce
qui se passait sous staline l'union
soviétique c'était une caricature
sanglante et nous justement n'a rompu
avec ce qui a été le style ni ces crimes
le goulag pour montrer que le communisme
le socialisme dans l'emoa ils sont un
peu c'est pas du tout ça c'est c'est
exactement la règle et vous quelle est
la différence non là on a une différence
qu'elle dit elle attend d elle elle dit
dans le numéro d'avril de lutte des
classes elle vous accuse de dérives
petite bourgeoisie c'est pas grave a
appris que vous savez la formule latine
puis bénéat mad men et castille gat qui
a mis 1 h à tva châtie bien
qui parle latin et l'autre suédois ces
salles avantage avec sa nature
si c'est la même chose les points
essentiels j'attends les cônes
essentiels on est d'accord c'est ça
qu'on fait des élections ensemble et par
exemple notre caractéristique c'est
qu'on est la seule force de gauche a pas
être au gouvernement et être fiers d'eux
pas être au gouvernement tu es même
d'être contre la politique 2 mêlera pas
très intéressant car des différences on
veut pas fusionner on n'a pas la même
pratique pas le même fonctionnement n'a
pas la même pratique quotidienne par
exemple on sait qu'il ya un secteur que
vous à lutte ouvrière je dirais que
lutte ouvrière a une vision de la
politique uniquement limitée aux usines
nous on pense qu'aujourd'hui bien sûr il
y avait huit dans les entreprises très
importante mais ce qu'on fait il faut
être avec les sans papiers il faut être
dans la lutte des femmes avec la marche
mondiale des femmes il faut aujourd'hui
à se battre pour tout l'est avec toutes
les luttes écologiques homérique à elles
toutes les batailles qu'ils
sont plus ouvriériste enfin je dis à mon
avis c'est le désaccord qu'on peut avoir
c'est une pratique plus limité hier sur
le fond la brousse en juin 1999 j'ai
fait une liste commune d'ailleurs avec
lutte ouvrière pour les européennes vous
avez obtenu là ça marche déjà mieux pour
vous êtes unicef et 5.2 et oui ces
femmes et les européennes alors que
beaucoup de gens sensés pas mal
peut-être en tous les cas vous avez été
élue au parlement européen est ce que
vous irez en sanglots municipal avec un
état qui en 2001 je l'espère va voir moi
j'espère qu'il y aura un trop gros pour
résumer tout ce que vous le dites là
c'est pas la révolution avec un grand r
un jour c'est tous les jours sur des
points très précis
révolutionnaire le terme comme ça
d'ailleurs c'est très marrant c'est que
quand vous demandez aux gens ce que vous
êtes révolté le mot révolte plus peur un
mois après je joue au vieux combattant
encore hier 30 40 ans la révolte c'était
les anarchistes avaient un show haut en
couleur ça foutait là tout alors la
révolution tel que nous on l'entend
c'est à dire un changement de société au
contraire c'est donner un contenu
positif à la région il faut qu'on à
vendre le respect sinon
ouais vous ça vous fait rien vous avez
le public ouais là le public qui nous
réunit est les gens souhaitent dur là
les gens souffrent elle est proche aux
invités et m'ouvrir
bien alors là crie vive vous êtes né en
1941 d'un père de dentiste le juif
intellos de gauche et alors il vous est
arrivé une histoire extraordinaire un
jour dans l'appartement où vous étiez
avec votre mère et votre frère jumeau
pascaline a un frère jumeau qui
s'appelle faire jumeaux je prête roger
gicquel je me dis c'est bien non c'est
un super voilà c'était un vrai jumeau ça
m'aurait aidé parce qu'on pouvait s'en
plaint mais séparément et faire
fonctionner un pub bon et alors
extraordinaire vous êtes donc dans vos
berceau tous les deux avec votre frère
faux jumeaux hubert la gestapo débarque
dans l'appartement donc en n'étant pas
42 à peu près et les gens de la gestapo
disent enfin les mélodies ce sont des
beaux enfants et repartent est ce que
cette histoire est vraie bah moi je m'en
rappelle plus mais ce que ma mère m'a
raconté parce que mon père se cachait
comme tous les juifs à paris donc il
n'était pas à la maison c'est ce que ma
mère a raconté je crois pas qu'elle elle
a menti c'est incroyable cette histoire
ça peut arriver un joint il avoir deux
types de la gestapo comme ça il ya eu
des d'autres enfants comme ça qu'ils
sont si mal ce soir extraordinaire oui
en plus ils ont dit deux beaux enfants
juifs à vous êtes les noms
alors est ce que c'est vrai que cette
chance liminaire comme ça dans votre vie
vous a laissé du recul la dérision de
l'humour parce que finalement tout ce
que vous vivez depuis l'âge de l'annoncé
du rab
oui ma faim je veux pas dire que ça
serait mentir de dire je suis devenu
anti fasciste depuis l'âge de 6 mois
quand le type de nesta peau non non la
presse est venue des convictions il ya
mes frère plus âgé parce que j'ai été
cinq dans la famille qui était au parti
communiste
à 14 ans vous rentrez aux jeunesses
communistes si vous vendez l'huma comme
jacques chirac oui
oui bah oui oui j'irai bien sûr assis il
a signé l'appel de stockholm a là un
appel pour la paix et la vendée ainsi
que woods universalis
c'est à la dure
c'est vrai que votre appartement été
bombés par l'ouest appartement de
service et j'habitais j'habitais chez
mes parents et dans une pièce un peu à
pas et oui au moment de l' os là il à
dire pendant la guerre d'algérie quand
l'extrême droite a commencé à plastique
et je dis ça parce que c'est un peu
oubliés ils ont fait sauter oui c'est ça
ma pièce quoi mais j'étais pas là alors
en 57 vous allez à premier voyage à
moscou et vous revenez sans rien comme
si de rien n'était excusez moi de vous
dire ça mais enfin quand même dans 57 il
y avait déjà eu budapest en 57 c'est en
56 budapest vous revenez en disant tout
va bien la preuve c'est qu'en 59 vous
rentrez l'union des étudiants
communistes et au parti communiste
français est-ce que c'est pas bizarre
d'être elle en urss en 57 et de rester
communiste en revenant est-ce que c'est
pas excusez moi alain j'allais répondre
mais est-ce que c'est pas un peu comme
ces ces artistes français qui allaient
en 37 38 39 dans l'allemagne nazie qui
revenait en disant tout va bien moi
j'avais 16 ans je crois que c'est très
important et à 16 ans je veux dire
j'étais invité au festival de la
jeunesse qu'il ya une espèce de deux
festivals de poudre aux yeux mais il y
avait des dizaines de milliers de jeunes
qui venaient on était servi comme des
rois et on nous a fait voir ce qu'ils
ont voulu nous faire voir je veux dire à
16 ans en plus faut bien comprendre
c'est que le stalinisme a été quelque
chose d'épouvantable on est bien placé à
savoir sur tout ce qui compte non
courants trotskistes et bien
tué par staline mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que beaucoup de gens à adhérer au
parti communiste dont moi pas parce que
on était stalinien au sens on adorait un
tyran c'est parce qu'on a cru
malheureusement que staline c'était le
socialisme c'était la révolution
d'octobre et l émancipation et du coup
sinon on comprendrait pas pourquoi des
millions d'ouvriers cassés et ont adhéré
au parti communiste était pas pourra
lire et une saloperie qu'il peut faire
vraiment une cause progressive effet
après mais assez vite ce pape ont vanté
d'avoir essaimé en 66 d'être viré vous
êtes viré alors je sais pas très bien ce
que ça veut dire vous avez expliqué pour
travail fractionnel anti-parti ça veut
dire quoi ça à l'époque c'était le parti
communiste ans était un des plus
t'aligner le reconnaît maintenant elle a
fallu du temps j'étais dirigeant des
étudiants commises et la sorbonne était
assez nombreux que cela a été six ans à
l'époque et on a à la fois commencé à
contester le stalinisme bien à l'époque
des cons contester on était foutu à la
paresse des projets été mis dehors alors
en 68 vous avez la preuve que finalement
une révolte est possible dans un pays
capitaliste moderne avancé vous avez
aussi la preuve que les partis de gauche
ne veulent pas vraiment prendre le
pouvoir parce que ni le pc ni lé ps à
l'époque malgré charléty ont voulu
prendre le pouvoir mais est-ce que ce
que je crois effectivement c'est que la
gauche voulait pas prendre le pouvoir ce
qu'il va pouvoir qui venait de la rue et
les ouvriers ont suivi les étudiants
comme parce que c'était des nouvelles
formes de lutte n'a eu que depuis 30 ans
était bastille république république
bastille clés de l'édifice les
traîne-savates là ils sont aperçu
qu'avec un mouvement un peu plus
radicale massif le gouvernement
commençait à reculer mais quand le
problème du pouvoir s'est posé ça c'est
une autre paire de manches et à jussiê
qui perd ça faisait plus confiance ni à
gsma ni à cohn bendit est ce à dire
qu'ils sont quand on voit ce qu'ils sont
devenus qui va en parler alors il ya
deux hommes de droite qu'a compris il ya
deux hommes de droite qui ont compris
jusqu'où le pc n'irai jamais c'est de
gaulle qui emporte la mise en balançant
la carotte des élections et c'est
mitterrand donc que vous qualifiez au
passage d'homme de droite qui lui fait
le programme commun pour casser le parti
communiste et vous à ce moment-là vous
fondez la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire alors en parler
d'aujourd'hui les députés européens et
vous parlez du du parlement européen sap
inquiétant ce que vous dites vous dites
qu'il abhorre l'hémicycle du parlement
européen évident
sauf le premier jour quand elles étaient
les uns avouent dit que par contre c'est
très bizarre parce que l'hémicycle est
évident mais les tribunes sont pleines
parce que le parlement européen c'est un
circuit touristique absolument il ya des
cars qui arrive c'est une demi-heure de
visite à l écart des lycées des collèges
il ya des buveurs de bière bavaroise il
ya les fleuri ça je veux dire ça ça
vient de tout partout je reste une demi
heure et il voit un hémicycle vide mais
se gagne sagan d'ubs les députés
européens c'est pas mal oui parce que
sans rivale non le salaire c'est le
salaire d'un député français c'est 35
mille francs mais il ya des impôts là
dessus car après il ya tout le reste
par exemple on lui fit les assistants
vous avez 60 mille francs pour pays à 6
ans ils prennent leur soeur et prennent
leurs copines c'est insensé c'est une
caricature de démocratie et ça explique
pourquoi l'europe tout le monde s'en
fout alors qu'ils s'y prend des
décisions je veux dire on a quinze
personnes qui dirigent 300 millions de
vin et le fameux conseil c'est pas le
parlement qu'il excelle on sait on a
quinze personnes non élues qui font la
pluie et le beau temps qui peuvent
privatiser la poste la spa mais pour 370
millions de personnes et nous on est là
dedans un peu des pantins on amuse un
peu la galerie on a un peu de pouvoir
mais parfaite et skate c'est comme ça on
pourrait maintenant être faudrait il ya
un public oui comme généralement on est
quatre ans et en celui qui va parler il
veut pas être à la bourre celui qui
parle c'est une minute général ou deux
minutes et puis celui qui a parlé macha
toujours cinq minutes quand j'ai parlé
une minute par politesse passée donc il
va parler vocaux général on est quand
même 5 alors que sont devenus vos amis
gauchistes la de l'époque là parce que
serge july par exemple le patron de
libération il va bien vous dites il me
donnait toujours été toujours le plus
prompt à me faire des cours de morale
politique mais aujourd'hui vous trouvez
qu'il a tourné comment il a tourné
peut-être pas dans le bon sens mais ça
va lui il avait voulait prendre le
pouvoir en 68 plus tôt par les armes
parce qu'ils étaient maui ces cas là il
a pris le pouvoir d'un canard très
pacifiquement c'est plus le même sans
rien qu'on puisse dire on veut savoir
son journal marche bon cohn bendit alors
vous dites qu'il est plus pour la
dictature du prolétariat mais qui l'est
en revanche sur la dictature des marchés
pas que je reproche c'est comme il le
reconnaît lui-même comme manipule au
parlement européen avec moi je dis là il
a gardé de beaux restes sur le racisme
d'antiracisme lentilles minatchy bien
pas de problème mais lui-même le
reconnaît il a changé il est devenu
libéral mais il est pour le libéralisme
mais pas en cause le capital et le
canada dry de ce qu'il était en 68 oui
on peut dire ça comme ça sans faire de
pub tu veux qu'on rentre et voilà
non d'accord rien à dire
dites moi vous alors est ce que vous
attendez pas pour conclure là dessus est
ce que vous attendez pas un petit peu la
révolution comme les monarchistes
attendre la restauration c'est à dire
est ce que finalement vous n'êtes pas là
où on va j'attends là où vous êtes vous
connaissez votre surnom c'est comment
vous appelle quand même et on m'a jamais
appelé comme ça sa joie qui a dit ça
c'est pas vrai en plantes non
mais j'avais dit j'avance lentement
comme un vieux glaciers ça c'est beau
c'est joli non même si la révolution
comme les royalistes parce qu'à mon avis
les royals ici peuvent attendre
longtemps deuxièmement je n'attends pas
la révolution mais j'espère que petit à
petit à travers toutes les luttes qu'on
mène aujourd'hui on va arriver un jour
un grand mouvement qui va changer
radicalement 7 sera bien là c'est sûr
que j'y croyais toujours à beaucoup de
messine et sinon je militerai pas je
vous dis moi je milite pas parce que
pour avoir un siège parce que j'ai pas
un politicien navette est simple j'ai
des convictions fait tout drôle
aujourd'hui je parle sont heureusement
j'ai des convictions depuis vingt ans -
40 ans et quand je vois la situation
autour de nous je vois pas pourquoi je
changerais je pense qu'on a encore plus
de raisons de se révolter aujourd'hui
qu'en 68 les riches sont plus en plus
riches et les quarts 70 je veux dire il
n'y avait pas de chômage avait pas le
peigne et paccard mobile ou bien alors
on va passer à l'interview nul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
bien alors l'interview nul vous allez
voir c'est très très con c'est normal ça
s'appelle comme ça donc sinon ça
s'appellerait pas l'interview nul voila
est-ce que vous préfériez d'hitler ou
staline gens préfèrent aucun mais on
compare pas donc je vais s'il fallait
choisir je choisirais a certainement pas
hitler
maintenant la dialectique 14 ans il est
déjà dans le coup un temps c'est un peu
ce lien il est au courant alors tiens
voilà
imaginez que vous croyez la
réincarnation vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en giscard balladur ou
raymond barre terry a maintenant mais
c'est à vous êtes amis de tiberi je
préfère peut être un canon ne vais pas
me répondre ça à chaque fois c'est un
composé des shows giscard notamment la
giscard balladur ou bah voila c'est un
jeu c'est pas parce que balla diop à ce
que moi je ferais rire les gens ah oui
d'accord sympa
est-ce que vous donnez plus de
circonstances atténuantes écoutez bien
ré compliquée celle là à à des vieux qui
se tape des jeunes ou à des jeunes qui
tapent sur des vieux car les jeunes qui
tapent sur des vieux où ils ont plus de
constance atténuantes nord - à moins de
5 en trois sets et niort a way non c'est
moi qui ont renversé la question accord
donc il vaut mieux être un vieux qui se
tape des jeunes 15 jeunes qui tapent sur
un vieux d'accord entre pas de sexe et
pas mangé pendant dix ans vous
choisiriez quoi
compliquer compliqué le camarade pas de
sexe parce que si vous mangez pas
pendant dix ans toute manière il y aura
pas de ces
collectifs électriques alors imaginez
qu'on soit aux sports d'hiver tous les
deux dans un chalet bloqués par la neige
moi je meurs de faim on n'a plus rien à
manger je meurs de faim et vous vous
avec moi à manger vous commencez par
quoi
le cerveau le crb on dirait pas pourquoi
a
servi pourquoi non le cerveau le cerveau
alors il est obligé de partir sur une
île déserte alain krivine vous
préféreriez partir avec un mec très beau
une fille très laide avec très beau une
fille très loin c'est pour y rester de
l'ombre une fille très laide ah oui
quand même vous n'êtes pas du tout à
fait tout le sel du tout du tout et
c'est pas une injure du tout du tout au
moins d'accord normaux pour moi non plus
la balle alors un ami débarque à
l'improviste chez vous ce qui vous
ferait le plus hot qui découvre sur
l'étape de nuit le livre de claire
chazal ou un godemichet
il y en a qui est un outil de plaisir
parait-il et l'autre qui est bon enfin
bref donc oui non plus plutôt le livre
de claire chazal vous préfériez qui voit
le livre de claire chazal que nkunda qui
voit plutôt le godemichet
bien alors on va voir si vous avez bon
coeur est-ce que vous échangeriez
votre paralysie générale vous serez
paralyser toute votre vie pour qu'ils
aient plus de famine en ethiopie
je dirais non parce que je le resterai
mensonger way dont j'ai là non je me
battrais pour qu'il ait plus de familles
au pied pour ça faut paralyser tout
faire il faut pas être paralytique pour
empêcher la famine pause
battu sent le mec a discuté avec les
copains pendant des années et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux